they've been locked in their compound
for more than two weeks and they don't
have enough food
we only want supplies they shout in this
video verified by sky news why are you
beating people
others even more desperate took matters
into their own hands
people ransacked this supermarket
shanghai is fraying under its lockdown
covered positive patients cannot isolate
at home no matter how mild their
symptoms
instead they're sent to quarantine
centers
this one hasn't even been finished
it is confusing and it is exhausting
jane polo bocco a ukrainian resident of
shanghai has spent the last two weeks
here after a covert diagnosis
she's since tested negative twice but
still has not been told when she can
leave this is the um
bathroom area shower area this is how
the girls are usually wash their hair me
too the atmosphere here just was
becoming more like people were getting
more and more anxious people starting
arguing with the with the medical stuff
on the regular basis i think the
frustration is coming from people not
being clear about when are they going to
leave how many tests you need to leave
others face even more extreme
circumstances
liang liang took a 66 year old mother to
shanghai for surgery to treat her cancer
originally scheduled for last month
but her mother tested positive for
covert 19 on a rapid antigen test and
now can't enter the hospital
[Music]
all of that is the price of china's
dynamic kovid zero policy a policy it
has said it will not abandon
if it did officials say china's
healthcare system would collapse there
are fears that the scenes in shanghai
could be repeated elsewhere in china as
infections continue to rise
guanzhou a manufacturing hub in the
south has said it is testing all of its
18 million residents after a few cases
of omicron were detected
in beijing some communities have been
sealed off the entrance is padlocked
they are terrified the omicron will
spread in the capital
this is only a localized lockdown but
this is where shanghai was just a few
weeks ago before that full-scale
lockdown zero covid can spiral quickly
out of control
the people are powerless
more than two years into the pandemic 26
million are still locked away
in shanghai they go to their windows and
they howl their frustration into the
night
tom cheshire sky news beijing